each year Microsoft Research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you for coming my name is Amy
Draves and I'm here to introduce George
Church who's joining us as part of the
Microsoft Research visiting speaker
series
George is here today to discuss his book
read Genesis how synthetic biology will
reinvent nature and ourselves we are at
a threshold of a new era of
bioengineering imagine resurrecting
extinct species are making humans immune
to all viruses a few years ago this
would have been science fiction but
today these scenarios are quickly
becoming reality it's a new world filled
with possibilities and perhaps perils
George Church is a professor of genetics
at the Harvard Medical School and the
visionary behind the Personal Genome
Project his many honors include the
Franklin laureate for achievement and
science please join me in giving him a
very warm welcome well thank you
everyone it's nice to be here I this is
my conflict of interest slide so these
are some of the companies that have
helped and other organizations that have
helped us take some of our primitive
ideas and develop them and get them so
that they're out in the real world now
the big question that you should be
asking of anybody like me and of this
book is why why are we doing some of the
things we're doing some of the things
we're doing are quite exotic and I won't
be able to talk about all these things
but you're certainly welcome to ask me
during the questioning or afterwards why
should we why should each of you do your
personal genome that's a big question
why should we do genome engineering as
opposed to genetic hidden engineering
why mere life why why should we reverse
extinction for some key species why
should we store 10 to the 24th bytes or
more and why should we study every
neuron and and talk to it first a little
history bill and Paul and I did
almost the same thing in 1968 which was
the hook we worked on a teletype that
was hooked up to a GE 635 mainframe
since then we've kind of converged a
little bit in our interests in terms of
Public Health and biology and
neuroscience respectively and both Paul
and Bill have funded me and I've gotten
to know them but the key thing that the
point that I'm making here is about back
then we we borrowed mainframe computers
we time shared and eventually we made a
decision to get our own and my you know
I I had borrowed many computers by the
time the this TRS model 100 came out in
1990 1983 and in it of course had
Microsoft inside and it was listed at
1100 and when it came down to 380 my
student while it opened up and I got it
and I and I still is still running
programs in my office
and whenever journalists come to my
office and they see these computers were
you know running programs that they get
all misty-eyed about how they used to
phone in there at 300 baud their news
stories on this thing it was actually
had quite an impact it was 20 hours
supposedly on double-a batteries and it
had a awesome 8k kilobytes of RAM
amazing what you could do with that much
RAM and and no disk drive so I'm going
into the Technic technicality of this
because it represents how do we decide
when we get our own genome and how do we
decide when we make a lot of
technological leaps so one of the
deciding factors is cost this cost comes
down enough even for even if there isn't
a lot of application software you will
do it and I should mention almost
everything I'm talking about here is
software one one way or another we might
write it in in hardware we might write
it in DNA but so anyway if you
extrapolate an extrapolation as always a
dangerous business and it's especially
dangerous if you extrapolate
exponentially
and optimistic exponential extrapolation
was to say that DNA since the 60s was on
the same core curve as Moore's law in
this since the 60s well very nice fit to
both of them at a 1.5 X exponential per
year so you could say well we did the
first genome pretty badly for about
three billion dollars when would it be
accurate and available to all of us
affordable sort of in the low thousands
and the estimate was the 50-plus years
you could see this extrapolate somewhere
out here past 2040 fortunately we had an
early arrival where the exponential
changed it's still an exponential but
it's a much steeper one and I'm happy to
say I was involved in that and I don't
know whether we should over interpret
the fact that it's flat now but but you
could argue that if it's not coming down
it might be a good time to buy your
genome now it's in the low thousands
it's always hard to buy something when
it's when the price is exponentially
decreasing and I won't go through all
the details of why this arrived in six
years other than 60 years but I will
give you one total totally from the
cutting edge of where it's going next
where it might start this exponential
again and I don't know at what slope and
that's called Nana pores and Nana pores
are basically a a direct interface with
single molecules where each single
protein pore which through which ions
are going sodium's or potassium and a
very high resistance sort of Giga to
tera ohm resistance of bilayer and as a
single polymer chain of DNA
single-stranded we block the island
conductance and so you see here is Pico
amperes on the y axis and time in
milliseconds long here and here little
blocks of 3 G's in a row and 3 T's in a
row and you can see there's very nice
discrimination between the four
different kinds of bases but there's not
such great discrimination between a run
of bases in a row it's hard to tell
whether that's three year or more the
good so that you can get on the order of
four percent error rate through these
and the the good news is the instruments
have come down
from you know sort of mainframe size
sequencing devices to handheld ones this
is not yet commercially available but it
is from a company Oxford nanopore so
that's it can either measure the
polymers meaning these long chains or
you could break it into monomers into a
C's GS and T's and throw one at a time
and that might solve this problem or you
can tag them so you can actually put
tags on each of the bases and monitor
them and that's probably the winning
combination and this is the slowest of
the new technologies to arrive I've been
working on this since the early 1990s
but here you can see how cleanly
separated this is a histogram actually
it looks it's the you typically don't
get a tags that are that are anywhere
close to the the the c's and g's and T's
and so you these are very well separated
baselines separated and the error rate
for detection of these things on the
order of these are single molecule
events with error detection around 5
times 10 to the 8th that's a really no
that's not a sequencing error rate
that's an analytic chemistry error rate
but it could turn into a raw single
molecule sequencing error rate which
would be unprecedented and wonderful now
treating you all is both as geeky
consumers you you want to know what kind
of genomes should you get so you can get
surf you know like in a sub hundred
dollars you can get snip chip single
nucleotide polymorphism but this is only
a 131 three thousandth of your genome
and it's not actually the best one it's
not even that informative a fraction the
exome is specifically the parts of your
genome which are most informative from a
medical genetic standpoint but it's only
1% of the genome and there's all kinds
of things that missus whole genome
sounds pretty good it's only 95 percent
but for some reason other we all call it
whole or complete genome no one has ever
finished actually a human genome or any
major animal genome but it misses
something that a phased genome will give
you so if you're gonna go out and buy it
with AI think you should you should get
a phased genome and this means two hits
in one gene can be distinguished from
a hit in one gene and a hit in another
so you each of you has two copies of
every gene and if you observe with these
short reads that you have two mutations
in that gene you don't know what unless
you phase it whether it's just two hits
in one gene copy and the other gene is
fine and doing its job and handling and
making you fine or if you have a
deleterious hit in both copies then
you're and you have nothing from that
gene and that gene is important then
you're potentially got a time bomb going
off so get a phase do you know is the
take home their second take home is you
it's not that easy to go from your
personal genome straight to traits you
know to determine the exact hour of your
death and what you're going to die of
but there's all kinds of cool things you
can do in between if you have a good
cohort to help you interpret them and we
have this awesome cohort called person
at personal genomes org and we we
collect all these data all this
intermediate and environmental data
because in part because the cost of your
inherited genome has come down a million
fold so has the cost of collecting big
data from of other kinds of omics their
folds and genomics you know makes so
forth and these are environmental so
it's how your immune system responds to
microorganisms and how you develop your
RNA and protein is all big data that we
can collect now million times cheaper
this is now an international project
they're over 2000 people in the Boston
branch alone the Canadian version is can
handle the rest of the world and there
are many other countries queuing up as
well we have an entrance exam you have
to get a hundred percent on it now this
is as it turns out one of the one of the
best projects for establishing standards
and so the National Institute of
Standards technology and the Food and
Drug Administration have teamed up this
is an great and teaming up to make a
genome in a bottle which means they're
going to take a few genomes and make
thousands of copies of them and send
them out to every company that wants to
develop new diagnostic tools new
instruments anything in and it might
involve genetics and so when they when
they look through all the different
kinds of samples were present in the
world they have quickly settled on ours
as the as the main one of the the only
one that really properly has consented
that people involved for rehabilitation
and commercial use either one of those
could be a showstopper how is it that we
have this unique cohort and again it's
because everyone has to get a hundred
percent on an interest exam we educate
first this is the world's only open
access data set meaning we do not
promise the identification because we
know that everyone can be reified and
probably people in this room and
understand better than anyone how in
this world is highly connected world how
easy it is to from either your traits or
your DNA or both in this case you could
identify people we make stem cells
available and many other cells available
through a bio bank so people can test
the hypotheses coming out of these
projects and we're collecting even
bigger data sets of all kinds of traits
not just highly medical traits but
almost anything that could impact our
way of living anything that can be
measured we're trying to measure it and
and this includes skin resistivity of
all sorts of cardiovascular components
this is a portable ultrasound EEG S is
not necessarily the best example and
this is the one that isn't portable it's
just fMRI but we think it's a terrific
stopgap for measuring the brain this is
actually slices through my brain that
fortunately they were virtual slices
rather than real ones now this one of
the reasons that people have hesitated
in addition to price is they think oh
I'm not gonna learn anything about my
genome I'll just give this generic
health advice and it's not gonna tell me
anything and if it did there's
thing I could do about it so I'm just
gonna you know take this advantage sighs
drink milk greens grains so forth yeah
well it depends on your genetics these
aren't enough so if you if you exercise
and you're hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
you can you can be dead there are there
things you can hand you can do to handle
it in advance preventative ly if you
know you have it but it's not part of
standard medical diagnosis if you have
lactose intolerance that's not good for
milk green beans if you have fav ism
with g6pd mutation that can be a killer
and many drugs as well certain grains
will set you off you have celiac disease
hemochromatosis is really bad if you
have iron in your diet and some people
do take iron supplements not knowing
they have hemochromatosis and so forth
I'm a narcoleptic yes so it's not rest
is not a problem and that's just a short
list there are 27 hundred of these that
are highly predictive and medically
actionable these are not things that are
you know weak effects there are finding
things that are weak effects there are
plenty of things we don't know anything
about but that's not one of the medicine
is about medicine is about what works
really well and there 2,700 that work
really well
so here's audience participation how
many people here do not have any
insurance whatsoever okay and it can it
can it can cost this is kind of group
insurance rates I don't know how much
you know I won't ask you how much you're
spending on insurance but the fact is if
you get to the end of your life and
you've been very very healthy and you
suddenly die and your house nothing ever
happened to it never had auto accidents
you didn't end lyme term care didn't
have a fire anything you could say you
wasted nine thousand dollars a year
right but you didn't know that in
advance so the question is why don't you
have your genome sequence right because
it could be it doesn't tell you anything
but you don't know that until you look
at it right that's fine that's that's
the end of my argument
and here's some examples of action
ability not just action ability kind of
in conventional medical genetics but
these are just a new way of do medical
genetics where people are getting the
whole genome sequence they're not
looking for a particular gene which is
kind of the way we've been doing it
since the 80s in this case little Nick
Volker three years old his guts were
literally the fecal matter was leaking
into his in abdomen he got dozens of
intestinal surgeries clear this was not
going well they in desperation they
decided to sequence him they found his
gene here is AP and they completely
switched the therapy to a little cord
blood transplant he was fixed within
weeks and and he is around the time that
he's celebrating his 8th birthday beery
twins misdiagnosed a cerebral palsy they
eventually they sequence that holds you
know found this gene and then they
changed their diet to include serotonin
and dopamine precursors just a dietary
change doctor Wortman actually studied
leukemia and ironically got leukemia no
connection just coincidence and then his
genetics told him what drug would be
effective Gilbert was example many
people who get either mastectomy is over
wrecked amazed if they have brca1 or two
alleles it's a preventative thing it the
but it's increasingly applied and here's
a case a whole family had a so not not
breast cancer predisposition but stomach
cancer this was killing their family off
at early age and 10 out of 18 people
that were tested in this family had it
and had their their stomach surgery to
preventative ly so there are things that
you can do some of them relatively
simple from a whole genome sequence you
don't necessarily need to know exactly
what genes you're looking at and this
phrase is an interesting new way of
doing science as well as doing medicine
which is we've been building up these
gigantic cohorts where we even draw a
single week per day
shouldn't a sorry weak correlation we
have to have 10,000 people but what if
we have one person can we do anything
that's maybe even more powerful than
correlation which has to do with
causality so and and furthermore I'm
going to take this another strange
direction which is are we just talking
about rare deleterious alleles are there
rare protective alleles that give us
super powers or interesting properties
or maybe mixed mixed mixture of good and
bad and here's an example where a double
no meaning knocking out both copies of
the myostatin gene results in in in high
muscle growth and decrease body fat flex
wheeler does workout but he has
obviously has an advantage and the
causality here can be proven in animal
models here's three different animal
species mouse dog and cow that all have
the same effect when they have both
copies of their genes knocked down
so that's myostatin we but there are
many other ones and this is just a
partial list lrp five produces bones
that are so strong it'll break surgical
drill bits pcsk9 reduces your lower your
coronary artery disease by about 90% and
there's an inspiration for a new
antibody based drug ccr5 is an
inspiration for a drug we'll see in the
next slide fut2 and ccr5 both result in
virus-resistant fut2
double null results in norovirus
resistance and then here's my favorite a
PP gives you decades of extra life
without Alzheimers in addition April 4
is a is a Alzheimer's risk it's about 20
20 times higher risks than if you have
two copies 83 I fortunately have very
low Alzheimers risks as I know that that
was a significance to my family because
my father had had problems so more of
the thin equals one this N equals one
patient happened to have you happen to
be one of most unlucky people on a
planet had both leukemia and AIDS they
treated his leukemia in a fairly
conventional way which was to find a
a stem cell donor who was matched for
his HLA first so it wouldn't reject the
the the the graft but they happen to
also luck out they could find a donor
who's only matched for not rejecting but
it had a double null both copies knocked
out of the ccr5 gene which is how the
AIDS virus gets into the cell it it
binds to the ccr5 so if you knock out
both copies there's no ccr5 on the
t-cells and this peak got cured of both
diseases very quickly and five years
later he's still disease-free as far as
I know from both diseases and inspired a
clinical trial which went through phase
1 and we're and now phase 2 which means
it's it's low toxicity and efficacious
where you take the cells out of a person
their treat their own cells with a
molecular machine of zinc finger
nucleases call which will cleave
specifically just in the ccr5 gene so
it's not putting some random package
anywhere around the genome where it can
cause trouble it's specifically making a
double null in ccr5 to put it back in
the patient and now they have a bunch of
t-cells are resistant to the AIDS virus
this is just what those zinc fingers
look like they're called fingers because
they have these alpha helixes these as a
sort of sort of nanometer scale yours a
little zinc atom it holds it in place
next to this DNA sequence you have a
very specific code where you can tell
how this protein will recognize the DNA
and there you have a similar code now
for a newer class of proteins called tau
or talons as I mentioned we're doing a
big data on on the various ohms
including micro biomes and immune ohms
we can not only detect antibody
resistance but there are consequences of
antibiotic treatment where you can if
you knock out enough of your micro
organisms the one will stay behind which
is clustered in difficile and this will
cause all kinds of gastrointestinal
problems one of the solutions which is
actually pretty low-tech
fecal transplant so you can actually
change your microbiome and it's probably
affecting obesity and diabetes as well
as this and you could change your immune
system as well we go around the world
you can find people that are resistant
to HIV they're very rare I mentioned one
already that one way that people can
rarely be resist is removing the
receptor but the other way is they can
actually make an antibody that's
neutralizing it's not easy to do this
with a with a vaccine but you can do it
with you can find a rare person happen
to hit the jackpot not because they had
just the right vaccine the right virus
but because they had luck with their
immune system and you can take that and
put it into other people so far this is
at the rodent preclinical testing stage
another way we can deliver antibodies
aside from having your muscle cells make
antibodies which is what's happening
with that those HIV neutralizing
antibodies is we can make these nano
robots which are a little bit smarter
than an antibody that they contain
antibodies those little grey things or
antibodies they're color coded purple
here and and all the rod-shaped things
are DNA double helix C's have been you
can design this basket basically which
is held together when these two come
together in long rods that that's just
two points that are holding this basket
together and when it opens up it
delivers its payload which can either
kill specific cancers without killing
any other cells or can do immune
modulation and it only opens up when
both of these double helixes breathe
enough so that one half of them will
bind to some protein on the surface of a
cancer cell and recognize it and when
both a and B do that they no longer
combine to their partners and so there's
nothing holding this hinge thing up
closed anymore and it opens up and does
its payload so this satisfies some of
the main criterias for what we would
call a robot that has sensors which of
these after MERS here that make a
transition
it has logic so it's a and B and you can
have more complicated boolean logic and
it has actuators which it opens up and
then delivers a payload which can be
toxic or modulating we're going to come
back to nano robots and DNA encoding and
in just a moment the bio bank that I
mentioned that we have for stem cells in
the Personal Genome Project can also be
used on organs on chips so this is
getting pretty sophisticated where you
can test drugs for their toxicity in a
in a human rather than a human cells
rather than animal cells but in a much
more realistic way so for example here's
a heart and that because has
contractility and a lung that has air at
the epithelium endothelium and blood and
it flexes with the air going in and out
so this all these mechanical forces are
much more realistic and there's ten of
these including neural and blood-brain
barrier which brings us to our last
topic which is brain activity map we
want people to be there's a whole
variety of neurodegenerative diseases
traumatic injuries this particular woman
is tetraplegic can't control arms or
legs
Parkinson's Alzheimers many diseases
that have a major neural component and
we'd like to be able to input an output
to them to the dual computers in this
case she has a small number of
electrodes going into her brain at this
point if the first time in her life
she's been able to manipulate give
herself a drink here by manipulating
their brain waves this robotic arm now
this is some of the work from my close
colleague John Donahue but the the point
is that this is still very crude and
slow and and and by looking only a few
neurons it's amazing that we can do
anything what we could do with a larger
number of neurons well the problems with
cramming more electronics in into a
brain even if they're just wires is that
the the the efficiency of integrated
circuits in terms of the amount of
energy that they need to operate if you
wanted to make this say
wireless or or in a variety of senses
either recorder or do input and output
it there's been this Moore's law not
just for density density of circuitry
but also for energy efficiency and you
can see that we're off by about 10
orders of magnitude from where
biological systems can do operations at
about almost 10 to the 26 operations per
kilowatt hour an example of one of these
that we're harnessing is DNA polymerase
this can go up to about one kilohertz
depending on the polymerase and we can
in these polymerase as we've found and
others have shown that they're
responsive to ions and bright showed you
earlier nana pore where you can convert
DNA into modulation of ion channels here
you can take ion channels and use it to
modulate DNA synthesis so we can
actually get this incorporation of bases
at making a ticker-tape essentially or a
long digital recording in it where DNA
is the digital media so this is very
compact it's about a billion times more
compact than any other digital media and
it has very low energy components as I
mentioned just a moment so here's a
paper we just published in science where
we did another kind of digital encoding
so that was one intended for monitoring
neurons this one was was purely digital
where we did a inkjet using organic
chemistry to encode a book 5.2 megabits
which were 5.2 mega base pairs of DNA
and we and this kind of exceeded the
density and in terms of its per cubic
millimeter of most other technologies
and the next step that we'd like to do
is we're developing this was digital to
digital essentially digital zeros and
ones to a C's GS and T's and next we're
going analog to digital so taking
photons and and audio-visual data and
converting it directly to DNA with no
mechanical or electronic components
purely of
photons to to DNA sequence here's
Stephen holding a book that you may
recognize and holding 20 million copies
that book in DNA form which is actually
a tiny dot in the middle of this red red
ring here if you missed this episode he
immediately wanted to eat it I stopped
him not that it's that particularly
valuable 20 million copies here there
doesn't really matter we made 70 billion
of them so I covered some of these
topics here ending a tiny bit early here
hopefully there's a stimulated some
questions I think I gave you a few
reasons why I think personal genomes is
now a very low cost it's like insurance
you should get it whether you are gonna
need it or not
genome engineering it barely got to
touch on but we've used this for
engineering chemicals and
fuel now being produced at about a
dollar 28 a gallon near Leifheit that
would be very hard to explain as well as
de-extinction yottabytes I think the
audio visual analysis a goal that we
have you can imagine having ubiquitous
audio-visual recording where you would
be basically archival storage where you
wouldn't read it unless something
interesting exotic or really good really
bad happened and then you would go and
you would selectively read just a few
gigapixels from that would be relevant
period full stop thank you
it's a great book however and I was a
little discouraged by your last time I
was a little bit lost about mirror life
um is there any way you can give like a
every second layman's term as to what I
was lost on okay yeah it's it's a really
counterintuitive so so let's see so all
molecules in the world can have handed
that's not all of them do but some of
them do so like you're left in your
right hand when you hold it up to a
mirror you get a mirror image of it and
but you can't rotate it so I can't
rotate my right hand and make it fit on
top of my left the only way I can make
it look like my left is through a mirror
so that's true with molecules too
and almost every molecule in your body
not all but almost all is chiral it has
a handedness to it and so think of a
tetrahedron right where each of the
balls and the vertices of the
tetrahedron are labeled it indifferent
they that's what the molecules are like
and it's really because carbon is has
tetrahedral symmetry and has this you
know if everything were made up of
simpler bonds and it wouldn't have this
problem
well the separate for my ecosystem is
partially true and the keeping under
control is only if we intentionally do
that because the here's a scenario which
is if you create of if you worked if we
were to create a mirror mirror lie it
wouldn't be completely separate from
ecosystem and that there are a few foods
that are common so acetate glycerol and
glycine are three top ones and so they
could steal all of that and incorporate
it their body they could not be eaten by
anything alive today right because all
of the enzymes all the viruses and
everything have a certain hand in this
they expect so this is a so you'd have
to be very intentional about this and in
fact many of the things I'm reason
raising the book are not because I'm
into science fiction or a big there
they're actually approaching much more
quickly than we think and we need to
talk about them a little bit in advance
so that we don't just accidentally
create something that will suck down all
the carbon dioxide problems which they
get sick they don't leaders we created
former if you could do that for all this
LJ it wouldn't be impacted by anything
that's exactly right but so but you need
to be very careful you need to have it
on a leash so you so Stiles you're
particularly harm hazardous because
unlike say e.coli which is another
industrial microorganism that we work
with a lot that one actually has to eat
food but algae is just using minerals
and carbon dioxide all the inorganic
stuff and so literally it could it could
suck down all the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere so we may think we have too
much carbon dioxide right now but if we
lost it all we'd have an opposite
problem to global warming so I'm not
sure I answered your question completely
but if you had a molecule you create a
mirror of it right what's the so you do
that chemically yeah you could do that
chemically and why so why okay so so
here was one description if we can keep
them under control we can increase
productivity and done right we can
increase safety imagine that everything
in the world that rots rope clothing
would so forth these are actually good
materials but they're they're they're
displaced by materials to the extent
that they can be displaced that don't
rot but you could make biological
materials that would persist in the
human body without causing an immune
response or they're much lower immune
response and they won't degrade so
artificial
you know molecular devices I described
or even physically large devices
implants and so forth it just and it
also brings a whole new set of chemistry
that it's not just twice as much
chemistry right and left-handed it's all
that at every position in the polymer
you can think of it as a long tape it
can be either right or left-handed so
it's it's not just to its
go to the end where n is the length of
your polymer so in the science in
science fiction but Peter what starfish
it's about a mirror-like organism so I
just happen to have the faster
metabolism so they eat us out of house
and home they don't even have that fat
metabolism all they have to do is not
die
yeah that's what the benefits other than
a doomsday scenario would be respecting
their life and I think you're the answer
in terms of these longer things for time
thought about with that then why that
you maybe would create a mirror life
ability to break that down so that
otherwise we just like super plastics
I'm building the great well I think we
have to be they have to be careful about
that I mean we have to be careful not
only about the things we create but the
things we use to control them because
let's take antibiotics okay
there's no quite a large number of them
and one by one we're running out of them
right you know maybe he had you know 12
major classes 100 minor classes and as
may be developed drug resistance they're
no longer useful you just crossed off
the list we only have two kinds of
chirality right and left-handed if we
use up the second one that's it okay so
that's one way to do it the other way to
put them on a metabolic leash that is to
say they are dependent upon something
that only only we have in the laboratory
right and that's even easier to do for
mirror life but it's something we would
there's there are ways we can make my
virus resistant without mirror so we
changed a genetic code
it's another way of a virus resistant
but all these things we developed we're
practicing under controlled conditions
how we can keep them on a leash and and
really testing that not just assuming
because it looks good on paper it's
going to work so we have you know
physical isolation genetic isolation
every kind of isolation we can so we can
do the tests on a small scale first okay
it was great this thing is like
ambidextrous pink
all right break it yeah one other
question um I read recently something
than one of the commodore aware of it
that there's some discovery that there
was an art a marker and his cell is
infected with a virus that use to detect
that cell has a virus and then cause it
to self-destruct and you've heard of
this yeah what's pretty remarkable yeah
we heard of it and we use it as a tool
it's almost every day so a lot of
biologists whenever they see a new tool
they apply it to their biology whenever
we see new biology we were apply it as
the tool okay and I think what you're
referring to is the CRISPR system but
there there are a few like that that it
basically there's two kinds two major
kinds of immune response one of those
one I described which are protein
antibodies they float throughout your
blood system and the other one are kind
of intracellular which are RNA that you
get an immune of interferon response
sometimes called so they have all kinds
of way of recognizing something's wrong
with there nucleic acids inside the cell
and these are great tools you can use
them not only for diagnosis and and
fighting viruses as you mentioned but
you can also use them for engineering
genomes this is one of my favorite
things so this is there are they good
viruses or is this like it seemed like
it's pretty remarkable like any virus
they could get rid of at your system
like if they
downside to that so there are definitely
good bacteria right so I mentioned the
case where if you don't have a good set
of bacteria Clostridium difficile will
take over your gastrointestinal and that
you don't want there are very few
examples of good viruses probably we're
ignorant but we're not that ignorant you
know their their satellite viruses that
kind of keep the other violaceous in
check they're a few they're not as many
good examples of good viruses there are
bacteria see yeah I read that into like
holy cow that's so the tests that we
have done is we meaning the field is you
can grow mice in completely germ-free
conditions multiple generations they're
there okay you know if anything they're
missing a few bacteria that helped the
vascular ization of their
gastrointestinal system so there is some
developmental feedback there but there's
no known consequence of having no
viruses now we have viruses in our own
genomes so these are endogenous
retroviruses and other things like that
and they go wacky in your brain so
during brain development you get a lot
of these things jumping around and it's
still an open question is whether these
are good for your brain bad for your
brain or neutral and so the only way to
test them is using genome engineering to
get rid of them from say the mouse
genome and this is very significant in a
sense that when these things if we're
you know recreating extinct species or
or doing transplants between pigs and
humans there's one of the concerns is
that that one of these retroviruses will
beat will jump species because of this
intimate this new intimate relationship
a personal genomics so question about
how do you get the face thighs right so
we published this in nature just this
July I may have the reference here at
the bottom yeah
I don't but anyway it was in it nature
in July and collaboration with Complete
Genomics the way it's done is really
cute
you take as few as 10 cells 5 to 10
cells you break them up so their DNA
gets a little bit broken and then you
spread it out into a large number of
small wells
so 384 but it could be you know anything
around that and in each well is about
1/10 of a genome equivalent and then you
amplify that up with an enzyme and now
in that well is that fraction of the
genome and now the chances are that you
didn't get two copies of each piece of
DNA the one from your mother went your
father so you actually get these long
things called hypothetic or you gets
basically you know that all at the end I
came from a piece of one of the two
chromosomes and so you don't get
confused between the two and that
eliminates all kinds of errors and it
establishes phase that you know that
these all came from your father's
chromosome or your mother's chromosome
and so you get two for one it's about
one error and ten million I forgot to
mention us and so you get both about a
hundred times better accuracy and you
get phasing yeah so look in July nature
there's a Russian about what do you
think about the privacy aspect it you
know it's one thing to do it for
yourself
right so privacy has changed a little
bit since we started this project in
2005 in 2008 Congress passed a law
called the genetic information
non-discrimination Act or Gina and that
prevents employers and health insurance
from discriminating based on genetics no
matter how they get it whether they get
it from your sister or whether they get
it from you or whatever they can't use
it and and I and and I think that that's
got teeth in it I can't imagine why they
would mess around with it it doesn't
affect long-term care and it's life
insurance but I think right now even
there's no law they're not no insurance
companies I know of is doing anything to
discriminate based on that so probably
what's happening is the opposite which
is people like me that know that they're
April III homozygous and are not
probably not gonna get Alzheimers you
know why why do I have any long-term
care right you know and so so what'll
happen is most of the people that'll
stay in that game will will be people
that are a very high risk of getting
Alzheimer's and other things that
require early long-term care so I think
it's gonna work the other way around
privacy you know I think it's it's it's
one of these questions in a kind of open
question is it is our genome gonna be
like our face because our face right now
is we have kind of a contract with
society that we're going to share our
face and our face tells you all kinds of
things about us that you might not want
to share you know tells us pre
accurately your age how healthy you are
what kind of emotional state you're in
your ancestry just all kinds of thought
right and if you cover your face you
could keep that stuff private but that's
not really successful acceptable social
behavior for most of us and em it may or
might be the case for our genomes it's
like it's like we are in a historical
moment where we're deciding whether it
was it could be like faces or whether
it's gonna be like something super
secret
yes sir tell me questions um could you
describe the process of actually you
know I'm I'm you know four year old male
like if I wanted to change a gene like
what is the process today of changing
that and is it just you change a little
bit of the gene you're like a segment of
a gene and a few cells or isn't your
entire body and this is staying locked
in right so gene therapy was very bad
ten years ago you would take a virus
that would deliver a new gene that you
were missing and would deliver it all
over your body or and it would miss
deliver it quite frequently and it would
cause cancer so instead of curing a
disease that causes a disease it's not
wasn't good and so that's set the field
back ten years more or less now we've
got this new generation of technologies
it's really awesome you have this think
finger nucleases are the talons that
will go to a specific place make it very
specific you can think of it kind of
like a little nano robot it goes the
right place and it makes it fix to one
it could make it to one gene or both
copies of that gene if you have to knock
out both copies efficiency needs to be
improved so is it take along with it
that section of the base pairs and it
can so that particular clinical study
that I described from Sangamo which is a
little company I had a small role in
starting in the 90s in that case they're
just trying to screw up the gene so it
makes it makes a double strand break and
it lets the body kind of where the cell
would fix it with an air prone way but
they're plenty we have the technology
that we use all the time in the lab for
bringing in a piece of DNA and patching
it in perfectly so you can actually
replace a piece of DNA whether though
that piece of damage it just hasn't made
in clinical trials yet but it's
certainly we do it on human cells and in
fact mice I have a center that I run
that's entirely dedicated to human
genome engineering of that sort
and this is sorry doesn't lock in I mean
once you've challenging it it's like a
library well it's not all yourself so
getting all your cells requires
efficiency and delivery that we don't
currently have but we have pretty good
efficiency and we're getting better at
delivery right now if you want to make
sure you've got it
you take the cells out of your body you
change maybe half of them then you get
rid of the half that weren't changed and
you put those half back where they
belong and you know you have to help it
out a little bit but I fully expect this
faster this technology is going we will
be able to get any tissue to any degree
of replacement you know it is if we're
in a way that it's not as committed
against the genes that you get naturally
versus inverse discrimination of you is
this a cosmic continuous takeoff thread
and we start adding our visually created
genes for competitive advantage in fact
it is the law of discriminatory I think
that law does not address that question
at all I mean you know what I mean but I
think this is this is just this was just
like a first step I think there's gonna
be a flurry of legal activity in the
future on this both positive and
negative but you know so far you know it
was almost addressing a non-issue there
were no really no examples of genetic
discrimination either in health health
insurance or employment the closes you
came as occasionally a basketball team
would require somebody to get a test for
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy which is
actually for their own good but that was
considered discrimination with that